[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos de la polémica desatada por
la participación de colombia en la feria
del libro de madrid en españa que elogió
al país sudamericano y lo eligió como
invitado de esta edición la lista de
escritores colombianos había provocado
algunas críticas pero fueron las
palabras del embajador colombiano en
españa' las que convirtieron del evento
en algo político quien aseguró que se
habían buscado autores neutrales lo que
daba a entender que los críticos con el
presidente e iván duque fueron no fueron
tomados en cuenta quiero saludar en este
momento a jonathan vocales director de
la flip la fundación para la libertad de
prensa en colombia jonathan gracias por
estar aquí con nosotros en cinco minutos
con está cayendo el gobierno del
presidente iván duque en prácticas
antidemocráticas que tanto le criticaba
su vecino nicolás maduro y otros de la
región como daniel ortega en nicaragua
buenos días pues yo creo que sin duda
este gobierno pasará a la historia por
haber sido un gobierno que como ningún
otro en colombia ha querido contar la
narrativa no en general ha querido
controlar que se está diciendo en el
ámbito de la cultura que se está
diciendo en el periodismo que se está
diciendo en los salones de clase y ha
tenido un componente además político en
toda esta intención no que por supuesto
es mantener un relato un relato afín a
su ideología política a la ideología de
política del gobierno y creo que estos
cuatro años han tenido un impacto
sumamente profundo en esas libertades o
pocas libertades no porque igual
colombia es un país que ha tenido
muchísimos problemas en términos amplios
y generales de libertad de expresión
donde ha habido mucha violencia contra
esto entonces creo que lo que sucedió
recientemente en la feria libre de
madrid es una
muestra más de un talante muy poco
amplio muy poco democrático que ha
tenido el gobierno en diferentes
en diferentes momentos de este gobierno
de que si revisamos esa cronología pues
nos encontramos con múltiples episodios
de censura directa de vetos a
periodistas y como digo de presiones
constantes a los diferentes sectores o
sea esto se puede calificar como como
censura
pues precisamente no la neutralidad para
ellos es lo correcto para ellos es como
parte de ese impronta que le quiere
dejar también lo que quiere imponer este
gobierno en los diferentes sectores y
ámbitos creo que además el mensaje que
manda es nefasto porque es el de querer
esterilizar las ideas críticas no que
precisamente eso es lo que hace que
pues se formen pensamientos que se
formen posturas hay que escuchar las
voces que son diferentes a las nuestras
y hay que escuchar especialmente esas
voces críticas y a eso es a lo que este
gobierno le teme especialmente ya lo que
le ha cerrado la puerta ahora ante esto
cuál es la postura de la fib
pues esto no había sido así de abierto
no frente en diferentes momentos del
gobierno de los otros gobiernos de
gobiernos anteriores anterior no había
sucedido de esta manera
y creo que sin duda sí marca una ruptura
con esa pluralidad con la manera en la
que se debe entender también pues este
tipo de actos no que más
irreverente que puede ser en la
literatura no hoy en estos días de toda
esta polémica por supuesto se ha dicho
entonces gabriel garcía márquez no
habría podido haber asistido a la feria
de madrid no que es al mismo tiempo el
gran
escritor colombiano y el que ha estado
colombia en la escena internacional
entonces esta contradicción y esta
congruencia creo que desnudan mucho más
a un gobierno que sobre todo en el
ámbito del periodismo y en el ámbito de
la libertad de expresión ha tenido unos
antecedentes muy graves y el más
reciente que ocurrió en estos días fue
el veto a un periodista daniel samper
ospina a un humorista que ha sido
crítico y ha sido con este gobierno pero
que eso de ninguna manera puede ser
propio digamos un motivo para vetar a
alguien no hay menos viniendo de un
gobierno entonces el mensaje es que
desafortunadamente
este gobierno a pesar de que en su
discurso público era más tolerante y
abierto pues no lo ha sido y que
desafortunadamente esto profundiza aún
mucho más en una situación del
periodismo que es realmente crítica y de
en términos generales de libertad de
expresión pues jonathan gracias por su
tiempo por estar aquí con nosotros en
cinco minutos con de france24 ustedes a
mí gracias por siempre acompañarnos
contenido con nosotros hay mucho más
para
[Música]